[Musique]
bienvenue à 24 60 ans elle s'est elle
rêve de sa vie
david saint jacques la réaliser en
séjournant 204 jours à bord de la
station spatiale internationale
le néo saint jacques si nous parler de
la beauté de la faculté de la terre des
relations humaines aussi entre les
astronautes de différentes et de son
engagement auprès des jeunes au fond
d'elle et saint jacques est revenu sur
terre tout en gardant les yeux tournés
dans l'avenir tourner dans le ciel
et si un jour il ne retournera pas dans
l'espace tout être humain
[Musique]
d'essence était uni retombées du cnt
allemands tombés du ciel une fois une
fois qu on se convainc que c'est pas
dangereux
vous savez
mais d'abord nous sommes chanceux d'être
venu méchant qui nous ait eu puis mais
je suis issu ce qui me surprend c'est
l'odeur du foin ici c'est super bon
l'odeur du foin c'est super bonsoir
bienvenue thème altéré sco qui vous a
accueilli à cette défense une fois qu'on
est défendue cellphone c'est ça que
c'est tout l'art est de réaliser
écoutez et un mélange d'émotions
vraiment relance parce que ces ferments
revenir sur terre c'est c'est la
terre-mère là ça fait des mois que je la
regarde en orbite que je la trouve
belgique ma famille est là mes enfants
sont là mes amis sur toute ma vie est là
et l'on s'est littéralement on tombe du
ciel temps vous vous allez vous dire
revenir les pieds sur terre
l'expression être familière prend tout
son sens quand on voit là parce que vous
perdez pied un petit peu tout le monde
c'est tout le monde est inquiété pour
vous à ce moment là s'il est rien et
c'est toute une expérience
il a monté un fusil c'est quelque chose
c'est très bon temps rouler ce n'est que
c'est un miracle technologique après
contrôle et revenir sur terre russe
tombé du ciel
on espère tard je souffre oui et puis le
bain sa femme avait atterri et lançant
ses membres sont lourds le sam a pris
par surprise à quel point sera adaptée à
la gravité c'était plus difficile que
s'adapter à la vie en orbite
parce que ça faisait pas partie de
l'entraînement que vous avez suivant
support non c'est parce qu'on était en
train de travailler là-dessus
non on se joue sans parler aux anciens
qui ne discours jacques toi et quand
vous êtes entré en studio tout à l'heure
vous avez vu cette photo de la terre oui
et j'aimerais que nous ça vous intéresse
les multiples photos du canada que j'ai
pris dans sa cellule
le contre la connerie tannique l'hiver
et koné sur les orbites change
constamment la terre tourne autres
arbitres tour mais ils on passe des
semaines entières sur des orbites
semblables où on est au dessus du
pacifique surtout est le pendant 20
minutes un demi heure tout ce qu'on voit
sur l'antique le nom du sang
l'atlantique on tourne qu'à reprendre au
montât pacifique c'est là de l'eau de
l'eau de l'eau de l'eau pendant 15 à 20
minutes et finalement on arrive la côte
ouest du canada
on traverse accordant quelques minutes
on passe au dessus du québec ce décès
mais orbite préféré jeter le musée le
colisée l'équipement photographie kanak
oui même voir votre famille ici au
québec et à montréal
revenir sur terre au sens propre et au
sens figuré au sens propre pour les bus
et réapprendre avez vous déjà dit être
un terrien ou plusieurs à plusieurs
chapitres d'abord physiquement
réapprendre à vivre sur terre
on a déjà kerry cette visite perspective
là vraiment unique
c'est plus une vue de l'esprit pour moi
je sais qu'on dit sur nous en ce moment
au genre dans un studio radio canada
mais on est sur une boule qui flotte
dans le vide avec une petite couche
d'atmosphère qui est comme une brume qui
flotte au-dessus de la planète et c'est
ce qui nous garde en vie dans le vide du
cosmos on est tous des astronautes en
vouloir de bercy bien spécial c'est la
terre en vie une boucle de recyclage de
ressources depuis des millénaires et
c'est revenir sur terre c'est tout
c'est comme revenir à la complexité de
la vie aussi par des années
d'entraînement j'étais très concentré
sur ma tâche ont planté pas faire
d'erreur et quand c'est rien oublier un
père d un peu toute une équipe
heymans de gens qui sont là pour me
supporter pour me rendre la vie facile
et henry sur terre
la vie est compliquée et celle
infiniment petit ou la vie c'est
compliqué où avez-vous dit aussi parce
que dans l'espace vous avez une tâche
binoche et puis de toute une équipe qui
est là pour supporter et puis ma
conjointe s'occuper avec s'occupait des
enfants de la famille de toute notre vie
sur terre
avec tout ce temps mais moi ma job c'est
de me concentrer sur ma tâche mais la
vie la vraie vie se complique à trois
enfants mais oui conjoint père fils
frère un ami travailleurs citoyens on a
tous ces rôles tous les fans qui vous
suggère ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils sont
quand même tabou et en même temps j j'ai
cru comprendre aussi de toute petite
sophie quand vous êtes parti en décembre
elle elle est partie à noël sans vous
sans doute sa dette
il nous vend aussi bien qu'il y avait
des communications mais vous avez dit
c'était aussi pour elle de se rappeler
de son papa parce qu'elle vous a vue sur
image parce que difficile mais elle
avait pas beaucoup de fond j'ai le
souvenir de moi mais en réalité c'est
plus pour papa que c'est difficile parce
que ces temps là ne reviendra pas de la
petite enfance et je me souviens c'était
touchant de voir arriver finalement dans
l'avion qui me ramenait du kazakhstan
aux bretons bien ces luttes apparemment
pas donc ça me rencontre est finalement
comme cela était un personnage dans la
vie de sa mère de bart poids ou de
bandes dessinées sur l'ipad
c'est plus que ça papa est devenu une
sorte de héros on vous a vu ils servent
en studio les gens vous accueillent sont
émus événements des autographes
c'est un état partie aussi de cramant de
votre mission de sensibilisation cap
déplaceront donc ça veut dire pour vous
et estrades aux essais plusieurs choses
d'abord il ya un rôle technique d'un
certain
un an un rôle de technicien d'opérateurs
se déprogramme ses poumons par rame
spéciale j'ai pratiquement rien inventé
et développé de tous sa maman maman ma
partie de ma mère ma tranche du gâteau
c'est de bien réaliser la mission
développé par des milliers de personnes
depuis des décennies et ça c'est un rôle
mais apprécié à l'autre côté fait que
c'est très visible
on est aussi le porte parole de toute
l'équipe ouais et ça c'est un rôle que
je prends au sérieux parce que c'est
c'est un message je me retrouve très
important personnellement qui montrent
une perspective qui me nourrit toute ma
vie qui m'a motivé perspective de la
terre d'où on vient où on s'en va et ça
je trouve que c'est très porteur comme
motivation pour tout le monde c'est un
peu l'un c'est notre avenir passe par là
d'où on vient où on s'en va on l
infiniment petit 1 vous l'avez réalisé
sept étages les tout petits tout en
étant un grain de sable dans l'univers
de doc seulement elles sont je
m'attendais à voir ce sentiment là
d'être tout petit
surtout quand j'étais dans mon
scaphandre alex heures de la station
tellement dangereux faire ça prend dix
semaines à se préparer à part et
l'équipement passe toute la journée à
s'habiller l'autre moyens matériels pour
vérifier car on sort dans nos salles
edwards en scaphandre est-ce que je me
sens petit et petit satellite de la
terre non je me suis sentie faisant
partie de quelque chose d'immense ah bon
le l'esprit main parce que la raison
pour que ce qui faisait que j'étais
confortable en orbite capable de faire
un travail réparé décor pu faire face à
parler à la radio avec mon ami à moi qui
ai tout le temps de contrôler janet qui
nous guide et tout ça c'est le résultat
du travail intellectuel de milliers de
personnes sur des décennies qui sont
jamais dans l'espace et qui n'iront
jamais c'est un effort d'imagination et
le doxie la puissance de l'imagination
humaine c'est sans fin je me sentis
faisant partie de quelque chose qui est
pas de limites lascombes inférieur à ce
qu'on peut faire quand on s'y met à
qu'on peut faire quand aux cimaises
simple votre guide toute votre vie
quand je vous interdis où il ya dix ans
c'était déjà
une première on vous avait témoigné du
fait que ça avait été un rêve aussi de
votre enfant c'est votre ville devenir
astronome camp depuis vous êtes tout
petit on va écouter cet exode dix ans
déjà
on écoute un court extrait le premier
moment où vous vous êtes dit un jour
dans la vie moi je veux monter en haut
là je vais monter dans l'espace que je
veux regarder ça de haut c'était à quel
moment me souviens pas que là j'avais
mes cheveux étaient des livres sur les
élus ni sage les les images de la terre
et de la lune et puis les images des
désastres des premiers hommes qui ont
marché sur la lune c'est ça me fascine
et c'était surhumain jeu trop j'en
revenais pas c'était ça m'a tellement
impressionné vous en avez fait toute
votre vie qu'est ce que ça vous fait de
penser que déjà de dix ans se sont
écoulés depuis le choix qui est cité
favorise ça va c'est comme cela qu'elle
quelques laborde quel privilège immense
de faire partie du programme spatial qui
est un peu comme le fleuron de la guille
activités de l'audace du travail
d'équipés internationales et ça c'était
pour moi le coup ci pour l'af une grosse
partie de ma vie personnelle et trois
enfants qui sont ni à travers ce rallye
d'entraînement russie tous sont
infiniment revenir waouh je suis plus
étourdis et poser un jour de tout ça
alors est étourdi un moment le temps
quand on s'arrête pour une brève pause
david saint-jacques rooney messi reste
avec nous poursuit cette conversation
dans un espace
[Musique]
tous ces discours de la nasa d'avc jacou
moment où on présente la nouvelle corde
d'astronautes dans deux canadiens et un
canadien
une canadienne six femmes cet homme donc
on vise la part il ya une grande
diversité écouter ce monsieur dit qu'on
va aller sur mars vous quand vous étiez
enfant part de votre aide totale avoue
rêver tout simplement d'aller dans
l'espace vous y est allé qui sont ceux
qui vont pouvoir réaliser ce rêve c'est
que 225 millions de kilomètres en fait à
prendre et 9 mois maintenant ça serait
pas avant 25 ans c'est mille fois plus
loin que la lune mars
c'est complètement un autre un autre
défi et les la magie de l'expérience
spatiale c'est que ça nous donne une
excuse me creuser la tête pour résoudre
des problèmes est possible tellement
complexe qu'on ne les aurais pas
résolues sinon et la pression bénéficie
évidemment de toutes ses connaissances
comme acquise et mars un peu une excuse
pour sa 1 8 mars celle excuse pour
figurer pour paul existe une excuse pour
résoudre des problèmes de recyclage des
ressources de l'air de l'eau on partira
pas avec des bouteilles d'oxygène et des
bouteilles d'eau on va falloir faire
communautaire ruscus en boucle l'énergie
gestion d'énergie production d'énergie
pour pouvoir revenir de mars
après cent des problèmes médicaux
terrible qui vont faire face aux
astronautes les risques de cancer à
cause des radiations et le fait qu'ils
vont vivre en confinement très longtemps
très long l'un des leurs de devenir
autonomes médicalement
c'est un problème aussi qu'on a sur sur
terre par des politiques internationales
faut y aller en collaboration je trouve
que c'est pour les générations qui
viennent
un beau défi et parce qu'il faut
comprendre qu'on n'est pas prêt à y
aller ça va encore dans quelques
décennies
donc les gens qui vont y aller sur mars
les gens qui vont concevoir les systèmes
tout ça ils sont nés mais cet accord des
enfants ses rêves le son dans l'eure
et c'est eux qui portent et vous semer
la graine cibula a rêvé à ça va comme la
matière
c'est ce qu'on peut faire malgré la
prolifération vous avez écrit vous avez
dans votre livre vous et l'espace aux
éditions la presse avec l'humanité qui
est au complet qui va aller sur mars et
non un seul pays
c'est comme une excuse pour commencer à
régler nos différends et à travailler
ensemble
vous vous retrouvez dans l'espace avec
un russe par exemple on connaît toutes
les tensions meurtre international
meurtrière que l'on vit de semaine en
semaine de jour en jour en ce moment et
dans l'espace c'est la seule vérité
c'est la paix qu'est ce qui fait que
dans l'espace ça marche et que sur terre
france et alors on devient frères et
soeurs on est tellement proches l'un de
l'autre
on devient on devient ainsi plus que des
amis c'est plus que des collègues en
devient vraiment des frères des soeurs
alors oui quand on est content on est
très content qu'on n'est pas genre très
fâché quand dj oriska des grosses
chances d'arriver on doit absolument
c'est oui on vit ensemble on a su
revenir
il faut qu'on soit ensemble et c'est un
grand défi mais c'est en même temps une
grande joie et une grande fierté pour
notre équipage tout l'équipage de on
irresponsable cette partie là et c'est
la politique elle est là elle existe
elle est vraie la raison pour les
complices des véritables raisons de
leurs ressources
mais entre nous c'est comme si on parle
des chicanes entre nos parents photo j
-ca le manoir nous on a on vit ensemble
nous vies dépendent l'un de l'autre
c'est une relation basée sur la
confiance mutuelle absolue complète et
absolu et c'est aussi je dois dire une
source de fierté professionnelle d'être
une démonstration vivante quotidienne
qu'on est capables de travailler
ensemble
c'est pas facile il accueillait plein
d'excusés des moments où on n'arrive pas
à le faire entre les pays mais on peut
on peut pas prendre tellement plus en
commun que ce qui nous sépare
est ce que c'est vrai que c'est cette
dimension là qui vous a peut-être le
plus impressionné c'est ce que vous avez
appris depuis sensible dans
fond cette mission de ces relations
humaines sept mois c'est monde date par
un peu le côté international pee ou s'il
le fait que c'est une aventure humaine
ça reste une expédition serre est un un
voyage
donc ça reste une aventure humaine et
c'était ce que des plus intenses et ils
sont revenus à mars vous aller jusqu'à
dire que c'est peut-être cette
expédition là un jour qui peut nous
aider à trouver les réponses aux
problèmes sur terre et a sauvé la ta
passion pour vous c'est important de
sauver la planète est un engagement
oui je pense que c'est très belle et
harris on n'a pas le choix
les fragiles c'est tellement touchant de
voir sa vue de l'espace je l'avais vu qu
est ce que vous avez vu de la sq aurait
vu je savais je savais on sait tous
maintenant intellectuellement que la
terre c'est une boule qui flottent dans
l'espace mais le voir de ses yeux vu
c'est tellement touchant parce que sa
flotte du milieu de la mort en forant le
vide glacial et rempli de radiation de
l'espace la bible et lun's d'une build a
une grosse roche le soleil son boule de
feu toutes les autres planètes pas
vraiment hospitalier plein à la terre ce
qui est un oasis quasi impossible là où
c'est notre vaisseau spatial on est tous
astronautes à huy ont laissé une boule
de magma qu'une petite croûte durci de
terre l'eau des océans c'est comme une
couche de vernis sur la terre
l'atmosphère c'est comme une petite
brume qui collait par la gravité puis ça
nous garde en vie d'un cosmos et c'est
tellement touchant je nous voyais comme
un alpiniste au bout de sa corde et n'a
juste une corde mais en même temps votre
mission qui était celle d'être
astronaute n'aurait pas été complète si
vous n'étiez pas sorti dans cette
fameuse sortie spatiale qui a duré six
heures et demi beaucoup de travail vous
avez du talent et à quel point c'est
être dangereux on avait presque peur
pour vous de coûts s'envolent
il s'échappe y avait pas d'insécurité le
risque de danger qu'est ce que vous
ressentiez l'intérieur autres le travail
qu'ils exigent une grande concentration
mais tout ce qu on fait comment serait
notre dangereux mais cela prend des
années s'entraîner c'est pour ça qu'on
tout ce qu'on fait notre entraînement
c'est juste pratiqué à répondre à des
urgences a des problèmes on a confiance
absolue dans les équipes complètement
dévoué au sol qui ont conçu le système
là le scaf ans
on l'a préparé pendant des semaines
après sa mutuelle man 1 et moi on
s'était vraiment vérifié l'un l'autre
tchèque cech avant de finalement osé
ouvrir le sas est ce qui fait qu'on est
la peur et la sai qui nous motive entre
paris mais une fois que tout fait ce que
tu peux faire une réparation de plus
peur conscient c'est pas possible d'un
conscient mais c'est parce que tu es
préparer et à répondre à tous doc
c'était en fait une expérience très
c'était très de très calme très paisible
et très sereine
l'expérience l'a donc vous vous font de
votre enfance jusqu'à maintenant votre
rêve réalisé ce que vous rêvez pour
l'avenir c'est vraiment la réalisation
d'aller sur mars et 100 selon je rêve
surtout c'est qu'on les sait qu'on soit
responsable envers notre planète et le
rêve fou d'aller sur mars
c'est comme ça va être comme excuse un
conte heures pour résoudre tous nos
problèmes techniques politiques
relationnel médicaux qui qui nous
attendent et on peut parler pour parler
de coloniser mars un jour mais on va
peut être les gens de coloniser la lune
d'abord faire très attention at on
poursuit cette conversation dans un
instant david saint-jacques madame
monsieur rester avec nous on revient
tout de suite
[Musique]
être dans l'espace a plaidé faire sur
notre corps qu'il faut qu'un peut
combattre
on devient un puits inactifs parce que
la plupart du temps flotte
c'est le fun flotter on veut allemand
pour notre corps c'est pas très actif
tout est très léger tout est très facile
et si on ne fait pas attention on va
perdre nos musées quand même perdre nos
eaux
ils vont devenir très fragile la seule
solution c'est de faire de l'exercice
deux heures par jour d'exercer sont
faits dans l'espace moi j'avais un défi
personnel
quand je reviens je être capable de
porter mes enfants sur mes épaules puis
samardzic alors quand je reviens mon
défi personnel apporté mes enfants sur
les épaules
est-ce que s'annonce un peu ce que sera
l'après nasa l'astronaute dans une
nouvelle vie après avoir consacré vous
avez 50 ans et janvier ou juste un coup
dur parce que sa marque le fait que j'ai
consacré peut-être que les 25 plus que
salée prend 40 dans les années de ma vie
à une chose devenir astronaute
la vie si on veut j'aurai mon obsession
réelle reste de tout comprendre
c'est un rêve absurde j'y arriverai
jamais mais je vais essayer de gagner
cette perspective là pour moi cet espace
à partager
c'est un peu seule ma grande joie la
partager parce que ce moment et c'est un
point de presse à l'occasion du défi
pierre lavoie oui vous associez l'agencé
spatiale canadienne au défi pierre
lavoie l'importance de faire de
l'exercice avec un véhicule une station
spatiale imaginé pour sensibiliser les
enfants et vous avez aussi un programme
à son hôte juniors c'est important pour
vous c'est aussi valorisant forces
participent à ce genre d'événement
d'engagement que d'être
en sortie spatiale oui on dirait que ça
fait appel à un autre partie de soi mais
le passé le bâton aux générations
suivantes futur pour une peau des deux
parents pour faire ça mais on peut tous
contribué à la boucle de la vie sur
terre c'est vraiment important pour moi
ça me touche parce que ça me ramène à
l'émerveillement que j'avais comme petit
garçon et avec tout ça et puis la ligne
que ça ma vie que ça mais ça m'a donné
non plus le grand défi pierre lavoie a
sur notre junior tout ça c'est des
projets des programmes qui ont pour but
de montrer aux enfants que leur corps
c'est leur outil principal c'est leur
meilleur ami peu importe le rêve qu'on a
ce n'est pas en santé on peut pas
accomplir vers soi dont j'ignore s'ils
vont sur le site de l'agencé ils
s'inscrivent ils peuvent gagner une
école un professeur s'inscrit peut faire
des activités
il peut astronautes peuvent venir dans
leur école
vous pouvez vous attaquer partout comme
une rock-star cvg
et puis un camp de formation peut-être à
gagner oui tout ça à travers mobiliser
oui tous à travers des activités qui
peuvent faire dans la classe que c'est
sur trois domaines la science technology
bien sur la santé et la communication
travail des équipes qui sont les trois
grands chapitres de ce qu'il faut pour
être un astronaute donc les enfants
peuvent se développer dans sur cette
thématique là qui est très forte
il fait rêver ouais et vous ce qui vous
a fait rêver donc ses premières images
45 ans alors qu'elles savent où ça passe
vite
la notion de temps à la différence d'une
carte on voit 16 ou combien de couchers
de soleil dans une journée
ouais faut faire attention au rythme
circadien quant à se mettre à lever de
soleil dans le visage avant le touché
qu'est-ce que vous rêvez pour vous pour
l'avenir maintenant ce qu'on peut
construire d'autres rêves oui sans rêve
on n'avance pas
c'est un peu notre responsabilité à
chacun de s'écouter et puis trouver
c'est quoi notre rêve c'est notre
motivation c'est ce qui nous fait faire
un pote plus à chaque jour et c'est pas
grave si on n'y arrive pas l'important
c'est de bouger grâce et grâce à notre
ère journée encore des rêves j'en ai
jamais fait mais je n'acceptais voulons
partager avec nous mais d'abord je rêve
de pouvoir qui continuent à voir grandir
mes enfants je rêve de contribuer et
continuer à contribuer et peut-être
d'une autre manière
la bonne entente entre les peuples
contribuer aux efforts de la neurologie
oui contribuer à une prise de conscience
et responsabilisation envers
l'environnement et qui est des défis
énormes mais une chose que me donner mon
expérience d'astronautes ce que mais n'y
a pas de défi qu'on n'est pas capable de
relever ces incroyables capacités de
l'esprit humain capacités surtout quand
on travaille ensemble qu'on va au delà
de nos différences et je suis vraiment
finalement rendu très fier d'être
montréalais québécois canadien yade on
est on fait partie de la gagne 2 ce qui
pousse les enveloppes et qui améliore
l'humanité gc je pense revenu qu'un
regain on vous a vu pédaler dans ce défi
pierre lavoie au moment de ce point de
presse des rêves pour vos enfants parce
qu'il ya un discours ambiant sur les
couacs s'était déjà la cause de la
menace qui pèse sur la sur
l'environnement sur la terre nous avait
pas d'enfants veut pas mettre des
enfants au monde parce que c'est trop
risqué pour l'avenir bien entendu ce
discours là oui moi je moi j'ai foi en
l'humanité
puis je sais que les solutions les
vraies grandes solutions les vrais
grands changements sont pas vraiment
dans la tête d'enfant en ce moment 1 et
c'est une grande ressource le début la
flandre le désir de vie qui dans qui
vient avec chaque nouvelle personne
notre responsabilité c'est surtout de
leur faire un environnement
intérêts qui peuvent se développer et
ont respecté leurs idées ils
je suis sam à je suis absolument
convaincu que c'est vers eux qu'on doit
se tourner plus écoutés et puis vos
enfants qu'est ce que vous leur dites là
dessus est capable esclave de thrapsano
annoncé son plus sale et pas à pas comme
que les enfants je vais te samouraïs
monnet paquet pour qui et c'est fort oui
manqué de grip astronautes pour explorer
la terre corse et la place dans
l'univers des fonds publics ce qui est
des saint-jacques merci d'avoir imaginé
précieux moment avec nous merci merci
beaucoup et souhaite un bel avenir sur
terre ou dans les airs que vous
retournerez dans l'espoir peut-être son
analyse les pronoms personnels
c'est incroyable ok merci merci on va
savoir
on espère bien voilà c'est tout pour
cette édition en série d'un cas 320
rachad merci de votre attention
à voir
[Musique]